this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on the
way to the beach in Los Angeles gray
block it down you know what's up guys
I'm coming up this weekend I'll be in
Bakersfield then I'll be in Wyoming
Illinois I'll be in Oxnard California
Raleigh North Carolina Chicago Illinois
Nashville Toronto Appleton Wisconsin
Buffalo Salt Lake City and Washington DC
that's all coming up the dark arts tour
this fall tickets at Theo von comm slash
tour t oh you are today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet some
people have a wallet and you know who
they are and some are you and these
people carry a wallet in the back of
their pants like some kind of dang creep
I think anything you put that close to
your butt is weird to me but some people
they like that and I don't like that
anymore I like our new front wallet and
it's called a Ridge wallet and you put
it in your front pocket and you can
throw all the extra junk out of your old
wallet you know your old wallet is made
out of leather it's probably part of an
animal what would what kind of leather
is it you even know camel oxen and they
this new wallet is a ridge wallet and
it's front pocket carry keeps all your
cards your license got the money clip
built into it and you can get a
beautiful discount on that on this item
and it's a fancy item and the item is at
Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo th EO so
get that Ridge wallet today's guest is a
man that I really admire in comedy he's
got his Follow the Leader tour that's
going on right now and the
congratulations podcast if you want to
go and check that out but right now you
can listen to us here
it's mr. crystal
[Music]
stars with just me and you or do you
start and then I go now we're in okay
this straw is cracked yeah you guys
first of all you guys have my rider
which is hilarious yeah
those of you that don't know what a
rider is maybe ya comics knowing
musicians but it's like what is in the
green room when you arrive to a show and
you guys literally have the coffee the
my iced americano
you got club soda water and then you got
my toothbrush and toothpaste which I
also get yeah what do you got a rider
what's in yours
I don't here's nothing I don't mind if
there's a plate of turkey deli meat in
the in the room that's the only thing
that's for mine that's a good one I have
so yeah I have this I'm gonna have
vegetables and then and then I have what
else do I have
Tabasco sauce yeah for what the salmon
that I also get oh yeah yeah that's
beautiful man
yeah and do you uh are you pretty
adamant about those things like right
when they get Roe those people know now
no I mean more they're pretty good about
it usually but some places you show up
and they're just like all right cool
let's start the show and then you never
get your [ __ ] and you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah but I think that that's
that has nothing to do with like you
know I think that some places just
aren't good at you know having your [ __ ]
it's funny it sounds like a diva thing
but like you know sometimes you count on
it to eat like you show up and you're
like I haven't eaten I can't wait to eat
that salmon and you show up it's nothing
they're like what yeah and it's just
somebody says yeah it's just a dude
standing there yeah yeah like we
remember this like reciting like old
vines you did like this yeah like
there's one of these into my salmon yeah
do you like you seem to embrace like
celebrity pretty good dude do you feel
like like you wear it well I feel like
really do you feel like that thanks I'm
just happy you think I'm you would
category it categorize me as a celebrity
I think so like I think there's some
comics that like some comics I think I
mean I think you still like it see you
definitely love being a comedian you
know yeah but you also I can't tell if
you like trolling celebrity or if you
love that like it yeah what is that like
you don't talk them out yeah I do
I like well it's the whole thick dude
like it comes down to like people ask me
also like why like
what you laugh onstage like it's just
because the whole thing is [ __ ]
ridiculous
the whole thing's ridiculous it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous I get to do
this for a job it's always it's it's
always funny to me that people come to
see us yeah do this [ __ ] yeah and the
fact that you can become a celebrity off
it is even funnier to me
baffling yeah it's just like you know
it's just like it every it's all funny
to me
like this shirt I got I like it you know
it fades in and it's got these two rips
yeah that's at least a little bit funny
there and I'm like are I'll get it cuz
it's got the two rips right you know
what I mean do you got any extra for the
right somebody yeah I don't know this
was I think this is just maybe from
Urban Outfitters so yeah a crazy thing
but like I don't know like it it's
always funny to me life is always funny
to me and then all the stuff added on to
that like celebrity and everything like
that is just it's just hilarious them
yeah has there been a celebrity you met
that you were like wow this dude is like
a like a like has too much celebrity
going I mean Kevin Hart's like that you
know I mean like just but but it not in
a not in a bad way I think he embraces
it in the rock I never met the rock but
like the rock Kevin Hart those guys are
doing it right you know what I mean but
then there's guys like [ __ ] I you
know he's kind of I don't know he really
kind of had his moment but like Ludacris
yeah and I met Ludacris it's like relax
bro
yes you know I mean he just had on
sunglasses and and and and all [ __ ] and
I was like we were indoors it was just
like bro yeah you have to act like
you're the I mean looks Ludacris was
[ __ ] huge but you got to act like
that's why I love being a comedian cuz
if you're a comedian you can do it
however you want you can it's always a
joke if you're a rapper it's not a joke
yeah you know what I mean if you're a
Tom Hanks it's not a joke yeah but if
you're a comedian you can do it however
you want to Wow like you have that
haircut I don't know if you think that
that's dope or funny or both but that
makes it dope to me right do you know
I'm saying yeah it makes it sexy yeah I
don't even know yeah I know I'm saying
like if you're like close it
yeah I'm this indecisive being a
comedian is the best life dude it's it's
it's you know when they say I hate this
[ __ ] live him live your best life but
like it's like dude I feel like I
figured it out for me like I'm the HAP
I'm so happy right
I'm so [ __ ] happy and people we talk
about comedians being like tormented and
[ __ ] that's not you know uh uh but is it
hit is there is that is that is there
like a hidden you there that in its not
but it's just not you I have anxiety and
[ __ ] and stuff like that and like you
know I always thought like people are
like well like people say you know to a
lot of times people say to let guys who
look like they get like who look like
they're like you know I think people
have this at least had not anymore
but like like with Joe Rogan and
everything like changed that whole thing
but like a comedian was this outcast
that was nerdy and you know now now
found humor and this is how he was going
to defeat life you know but now I feel
like it's it's changed because because I
think that feeling like you're an
outsider being an outsider doesn't come
from like what you radiate it comes from
who you are inside your head right dunno
I'm saying yeah I am that way right I am
that way and you know I think guys like
who are like Rogen's that way you know
what I mean you're that way and but it's
also but it's it's and it's and it's
like we don't have to radiate it we
don't have to live yeah exactly they
still have it and not live yeah like
Santino's like that you know I mean but
they're guys yeah they're not like these
you know what I mean like sheepish
writers yeah exactly do you feel like
there's a swing back for entertainment
entertaining comedians wait what do you
mean like I feel like you know for I
feel like there's been this thing for a
while where you could just be a writer
and be standing on stage yeah yeah equal
come and I'm like why would people go to
a theater to watch somebody just stand
like that something could be reading
whereas like some guys you go and it's a
performance like you see them yeah yeah
yeah you were like that massive ass you
Maniscalco
yeah yeah yeah yeah um you know I I just
wonder if there's more of a swing back
towards like I want to see something
that I know is is the real McCoy you
know yeah like I'm entertained totally
yeah I mean I think that yeah I think
that now you kind of with it with the
internet especially you kind of have to
have at least a little bit of it all
yeah you know what I'm saying I mean
there look I have
a lot of love for a lot of a lot of guys
should just stand there and do this but
sometimes if you stand there and you're
just doing your [ __ ] that is your act
and you're embodying that quote-unquote
character right but if you just have no
stage presence I think you kind of fall
to the wayside yeah I think nowadays
just with the internet right on YouTube
and [ __ ] people were watching and very
visual I mean look at rap now you got to
have orange and purple and pink hair
Takashi nx9 and face tattoos Takashi
Brown yeah nobody's about the nobody's
even about the [ __ ] music anymore
yeah you know if Takashi hit you up bro
really right yeah he hit you up there
like you get an email in the yeah yeah
yeah first of all it's awesome to think
that he emails how about this dude you
get a hour that drops a letter through
your bucket letter that's more like him
and the owl is yellow and purple in our
and it's in his eyes bro he's flying all
crazy high 68
yeah well I had hahaha yeah and you get
a letter and it's it for him for from
it's from him to come down to like
Dominican Republic where we keep him and
he lives do you go do you go oh no way
no for what you would I go yeah that's
but now I don't want to go well that
comes down to mean I don't want to go
anywhere right but there's a part of me
that would be like oh I be a funny story
but like what do those guys do like I
don't do drugs right I'm not gonna hold
a gun right that's all I ever see that
guy doing on Instagram so like I don't
want to do that [ __ ] you know this party
you want to do that yeah part of me
wants to do it because I know we are a
hilarious story yeah and it would
probably be 15 minutes on stage so maybe
I would do that yeah but like I went to
e3 yesterday you know that [ __ ] downtown
town of the game stuff video game thing
and I was like look they invited me I
was like I don't want to go but I like
watching video games kinda to see the
whole spectacle so I'll go and maybe
it'll be maybe it'll be interesting and
I went and I didn't want to be there
yeah
just because it was like I don't really
care all that much you don't care and I
was walking around I was like I just
want to be I want to be drinking my club
soda and [ __ ] coffee you know do you
think so many people pretend like they
care about [ __ ] because that's one thing
where you don't get hung up on is I'm
envious sometimes on my
[ __ ] the amount of free time that DeLeo
must have yeah sometimes and not that
easy not so busy but just said like the
free time you must have because you
don't placate yeah that's a cooter bro
you know what I mean mm-hmm
yeah I do dude it no you you get it he
[ __ ] knows who though he is it on his
back it's about it's about a [ __ ] uh
it's about you know barracudas when they
see the [ __ ] shiny [ __ ] they go
towards it you know if you if you're
fishing you catch a barracuda you got a
bracelet on that's your [ __ ] ass you
know cuz we're cruise like what a thing
and they grab it right dude
that's if you can't be like that as a
person you can't be like what Coachella
everybody's going let's go that's a CUDA
bro I'm not I'm not about that right no
thank you
I meant maybe I miss out on a lot of
[ __ ] you know camping kuda we built all
these walls yeah we figured it out why
the [ __ ] you want to get away from it
right why do you want to go back out you
know I'm saying so what have there been
coot things that recruiters in your life
and you're like now you came back to me
like all [ __ ]
I mean look like you know we're all I
always say I'm a podcast we're all a
little bit kuda you know what I mean
because you have to have that sort of
like thing where you're like oh [ __ ]
like I want to like like I have an
addictive personality for sure like that
that's like the hundred percent and I
don't do drugs and I never have and I
realize that that's that's that was like
a blessing in disguise
right because I don't ever do anything I
have all these stupid rules but like you
look like a dude that would help get
drugs too so a definite fit yeah in my
car like kilos yeah and I don't but I
don't have I I don't I have all these
stupid rules like one of my things like
I don't do anything until I regret that
I haven't done it like I lost my
virginity after I felt like oh [ __ ] I
should have had sex with that girl
Oh a series and I was 19 I waited a
while you know yeah but I never had that
moment where I was like oh everybody did
[ __ ] smoke weed I wasn't involved
I should have been right I never had
that moment so I never I never did it so
you kind of it's interesting so you
don't get tempted in the butt you get
you get 10th do you not get tempted in
the beginning or do you have this just
something built in you where you wait
til have some foresight does that make
any sense
nah um yeah I'm not really like that I
just don't I just if if everybody's
doing a thing it makes you question yeah
you
question first I'm just like what is it
what's going on it just puts me off it
it's not even that I'm questioning it
I'm just like right like like the number
one thing about that is frats like I
have never join a frat join right join
something are you out of your mind doing
some yeah my my grandfather used to tell
my dad
you never volunteer for anything dude
that's hilarious
that's hilarious and as a kid I was like
what but now I get it dude
yeah it's like that Lil Wayne song on me
dude yeah get out of here frat yeah have
you met little Wayne no no no I would I
would love to dude I got invited so I
got invited to this it was some Saints
after-party during like a NBA all-star
weekend this is like a 15 years ago or
12 years ago yeah yeah so I go in and it
ends up being this little bitty
conference room it like this um at this
Westin or something right and it's
amazing like there's so many like the
Kardashians are there before they're
like as huge as they are it's kind of
crazy Wow and then Mannie Fresh and
little Wayne Mannie Fresh Rob yeah
dressed like an astronaut bro you jet
and the suit was too big they should not
have put a big of an astronaut comes in
and he's literally wrapping and like and
they did one song and they jet it man
but that was close ever got to oh my god
I've never even seen Lil Wayne yeah a
lot of people in New Orleans look like
they're Lil Wayne oh yeah well that's a
thing there it's unbelievable yeah a lot
of a lot of dudes got that long hair and
then it kind of took off but I remember
hearing stories when we were young like
listening a B G like we Cash when he was
out it just blew up
oh yeah so crazy I know and you would
hear stories about him like having a car
just like he borrowed a car from
somebody like a Hummer he's 14 years old
and he every day go to school and they
[ __ ] take it take it from ya cuz I
shot my first special in at the Civic oh
yeah yeah in New Orleans and uh and I
went there and I hated that place you
know what every when I shot my special
there it was like the best show ever the
first special of course I like I have
this all it's a nostalgia for and
everything it was amazing and then every
time I go back I'm like how did he
like it was just like these crowds
unlike that the I don't it's not the
venue the venue was nice but like it
just wasn't I was like what is going on
is not good one time I had the flu of
performing there but yeah I would say
I've been back a few times and it's just
never been even a 10% of what it was
well yeah my [ __ ] it's awkward yeah yeah
I mean New Orleans is an awkward City to
perform and I know it's so music heavy
yeah people want to drink they want to
be outdoors you're gonna laugh just as
much as somebody on the corner you know
I know it's the truth yeah I yeah I got
it um so you have so one thing I want to
tell you about me you just hit a million
followers on history
yeah yeah that's pretty cool what were
you were there nights where you were
like there'd be a night where you're
laying in bed you're like okay I'm not
going to bed until this goes up another
thousand come on no I know but I would
be like I'm gonna go to sleep I'll wake
up let's see where it is when I wake up
no I mean nah I don't
yeah I try not to I try not to give a
[ __ ] about it I mean I love I love
social media because it's an extension
of you performing right I love doing
that I love like like now I can put my
podcast bits on there and it helps
pocket feed the podcast and you know I'm
control of that so was er so I mean cuz
hitting a million's is I mean it's it's
crazy bro there's countries out there
and I'm sure Nick could pull up a list
for us that do not have a million people
and I don't say there's a million
followers like there are kings out there
of you know probably small mixed
countries that do not have a million
file yeah but that's why I that's why I
think that like that's why I try I'm
really trying to streamline the [ __ ]
like I don't want people to follow me
because we're like okay yeah he's pretty
funny I want [ __ ] that are down
that's what I'm saying I'm always I'm
starting a cult you know what I mean
like that's why I say this is not a
podcast it's a call my podcast
congratulations that shit's a cult right
and when you when you when you click
Subscribe that's it
you're in you're a baby man right you
got to fight these cooties you know I'm
talking about so so these so I like this
so don't get in the world get it right
so so so that's why I created an app I
have an app Instagram that shit's gonna
fall by the wayside but you think so
well I think that yeah I mean look if
you have a blue checkmark they're there
they know
that and they want you to pay for reach
mmm and you can you can promote your
[ __ ] like sometimes I even see my stuff
like if I'm performing in wherever I'll
see a theater promoting it and it'll be
coming from me it'll be like crystally
and I'm like what I didn't post this
right it's because they put money into
advertising it but they know if you have
a blue checkmark it's like a backhanded
thing where you're like oh [ __ ] this is
a good thing I'm official but then also
you reach less people yeah like look at
that look at the difference between
Barack Obama and like Katy Perry
like I think Katy Perry Prabhas way more
followers but like she doesn't reach as
much because Barack Obama can't be
control cuz it's like a political hmm
blue check right Katy Perry that want
her to pay for that you know I don't
know if your game I don't know if those
people are good representative say I'm
like yeah some people that they know
that they're yeah they're advertising
something are gonna be sell you know
bringing people into a show they're
going to charge them to they want to not
reach the audience
[ __ ] that I started you know I I get
this app and then I'm sorry so I know
that now I'm in control of it that's why
I like a podcast you know what I mean
these people are coming in they're
subscribing to me they're not
subscribing to some app but now in the
beginning with podcast cuz I remember
even like Amy Schumer um she used to be
like [ __ ] podcast you know yeah
why did - right yeah and then you came
around to it yeah because I saw first of
all I saw people I saw people that were
making money off of it and then you know
I'd look at guys like you know well
Rogan of course is the is the man at
that and then but like Segura and Bill
burr and like where I was and I was like
oh these they have like a oh people it's
like a weekly thing it's like a weekly
thing that people kind of feel like
they're a part of yeah and they are you
know what I mean did you feel
competitive about it what do you mean by
that like so when you see other dudes
doing it like do you have that podcasts
hmm that's not why I started it I I
honestly started it like with like the
rapper mentality was like let's get this
money it's on the table like what am i
doing right and then I didn't realize
that how lucrative it could be and then
I was like let me just try to do it
without guests to see how long it lasts
and then I was like now it's just like
some stupid monologue that I'm doing
my [ __ ] house yeah but uh I don't
know yeah I just I just I might
competitive I mean I don't know like we
started at the same time right kind of
yeah oh uh I always like look at your
[ __ ] and I'm like aw it's cool to see
yeah but but I like I like you're like
my friend
right I mean so I'm not competitive with
you it's like you know it's like a fun
kind of thing yeah it's like seeing your
buddy like just uh that he's out there -
yeah yeah yeah yeah like I like that
you're doing yours cuz it's like it's
cool too because I see a lot of times
people are like Oh crystally and Theo
von - to podcast I love you know like
that's your man yeah but like you know I
mean it's like our cool like cuz I think
you're funny so if they think you're
funny and I'm funny than me that means
I'm funny yeah and I mean like you know
I know like yeah I remember whenever I
first like I think I feel like a lot of
guys are probably intimidated by you
like in the comedy space and I probably
was I think you know when I think back
but then like you know you've done like
some real nice things for me even just
like help me getting over the Laugh
Factory and like you know just uh you
know like you'll tag your buddies on
social like you'll do stuff that's like
super nice do you feel like people have
a misconception about you ever and this
could have just been me and my own
inferiority well I don't know I think
that people think people judge people
and that's fine you know until you get
to know somebody but if you're like like
I think a lot of people you know um you
know like I like fashion I'll wear a
cool jacket
I get what people think about that when
they see a long haired dude with a
[ __ ] beard and and a big and a jacket
yeah max Amini yeah you know you're like
you're like oh that guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he thinks he's funny get it also
an [ __ ] from like the seventies but
but you know but like you know I I we do
have to do you I don't yeah but also
like but like I said I get it's funny
dude
I get the jacket cuz it's funny right
I'm not I'm not [ __ ] Brad I mean it's
goofy gawking [ __ ] that's in his
head and like i like i also like love my
friends and like i want them to do well
dude I don't want to BS you do I don't
want to be honest I don't want to be the
the best stand-up comedian on a on a on
a lineup I want
some people to think I want to be some
people in that audience is favorite yeah
but like when I'm gonna line up with you
Rogan Joey Diaz [ __ ] Ali Wong and and
and and Nikki Glaser these people that I
think are really [ __ ] funny like uh I
like that people like them more than me
like that right because because it's
like we're the cast of characters in
this moment in history that are at the
Comedy Store or wherever the [ __ ] it's
got awesome to me yeah I've talked to
other comics that don't like that
they're like nah I want to be the best
I'm the headliner and [ __ ] like that
it's like who has time to feel that way
right it just eats you up inside I want
I want everybody to do as best as they
can for themselves yeah you know I
believe that I I totally believe that
about you man I think you definitely
have this unique way of um yeah you want
all your friends there with you yeah
yeah a hundred percent and I want them I
want them so badly to do to do well yeah
I want them so badly to do well because
because I want to do tours with them in
my head in my back of my mind oh I want
to create a show where I host and I
bring everybody else out on tour and I
want them to do well because I want
networks to be like oh [ __ ] yeah of
course we want that guy on tour he's
great I want you to do what because I
want to do well too right I want to do
you know what I mean it's like it really
does help in the end if you and when
people like when things getting when you
get inclusive and there's this weird
idea I think whenever you especially in
an entertainment industry of when you're
unincluded a yeah people were so kind of
greedy this whole industry is that it's
like we have to do it everything for
ourselves but when you get inclusive
that's when things really start to just
shine I feel like yeah well with the go
yeah absolutely yeah the more yuning's
loaf you know each other yeah yeah I
know a hundred percent guys that are the
other way and you know I don't wanna
name any names but comedians also were
it's a very singular thing it's just you
up there you don't you don't have a band
youth right you know I mean if you don't
bring an opener which a lot of guys
don't it's just you so I get how it's
very selfish and you know how you can be
competitive other about how many tickets
did he sell oh what's his podcast doing
on the show because you probably feel
isolated you know much they didn't you
that's how you see it but without naming
names I mean guys fall to the wayside
like that man yeah if you keep people
that you know if you keep people down it
is it's not good for you to it
it's not good for you at least that's
what I've seen no I believe that man and
I think actually some of that stuff I
think actually learned from you and even
learn from like simon rex like as a
buddy of mine and he like always
includes his bf loved that girl and he's
just so inclusive like it just and it
just makes him cuz then people are like
oh I want to know more about what's in
his world like I was back to more what
he respects and you love good humor man
you love it yeah yeah crazy promise how
much you love like you really love it
yeah I laughed so much dude I mean like
one of my favorite things to do is to
get you know sometimes you come eat but
like after the show is to like when
we're all making fun of each other and
one guy who eats with both em is he so
uses both utensils at the saw is that
Joe I don't know a weirdo yeah just
there's some magic ah go he's havin a
beard and then not having a bit yeah
yeah yeah that's Joe yeah he's a weird
right no it's like he works for his food
it has to be there yeah yeah yeah anyway
it always taught how it looks like he
has to jacket yeah only has one jacket I
always joke with him I say like it
always looks like you're wearing a
backpack even though you're not that guy
[ __ ] always is wearing a backpack I
don't give a [ __ ] if he's naked he's got
a beard
it looks like he was married and had a
family at like 9 years old like you
[ __ ] looks like he's been through too
much man dude how many waiters at
macaroni grill did you look like over
the burner I will tell you this straight
up I've never been a macaroni I know you
don't believe me but probably never been
a macaroni no I know I know I get it I
wouldn't believe me if a guy like me
said I've never been a macaroni girl I'd
be like get the [ __ ] out here I would
never trust that guy but I've never been
I never had that moment I was like I
should have went to Macaroni Grill what
is the number one place for people has
anybody ever brought somebody up to you
like that dude definitely looks more
like me than me Oh me yeah oh for sure
yeah yeah there's a few guys there all
yeah I like when there are more handsome
who couldn't but like sometimes I look
like ugly [ __ ] and I'm like ah
maybe I'm ugly cuz I get like I look
like a bird a little bit you're right
and and you know that's funny you got to
hone your [ __ ] man it's like you know
but like yeah some people I'm like that
guy looks like me and that sucks yeah I
got to change it up somehow next life
maybe or something yeah
that reincarnation do you feel so with
let me go back to this million followers
so I mean that's crazy can you bring
those countries up again necks are ewwww
oh really yeah well he did it oh wow
yeah I mean these are some countries um
haha yeah start with one for Cypress
booty Fiji Montenegro Macau
Solomon Islands I mean these are nothing
like huge countries but Cyprus have
heard of yeah
Belize you have more Amoz the Bahamas
mm-hmm so you have more people you know
that you can act like you have more
followers than whoever runs the Bahamas
there's some Owens WOM yeah Guam's huge
Guam scrums a big you know PR but
popular but it's 160 mm I got kind of
crazy we're even making the big of a
deal about it yeah I mean I got like
seven times now yeah yeah that's
baffling did you do you feel a little
more relaxed now that you got to a
million on yeah in social media yeah I
but there's nothing to chase now right
just in that way like I'd like I don't
have to get you know because once you
get like 950 you're like oh my get a
million soon and also even if you don't
you forget about it people always
hitting you up like you almost got a
million mansur like I forgot to think
about it but yeah now I don't did it
start to snowball were there things like
so was there a moment like where you had
like what what was one of your biggest
early jumps kind of and on histogram
yeah probably
when uh when I don't know like I'd get
like 10 20,000 sometimes in a day but
like like when Bieber did the ice bucket
challenge Rylan's me on that I got like
30 or 40 Wow you know what I mean
but I also like I like I said like I
don't want people following me just cuz
right I want them to follow me because
they're like you know what I mean so I
don't care if I had five hundred
thousand five hours I'd rather that if
they were like down for if they were
brother call Aslam you know like won't
be like WOM they'll go they're there
with Guam yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah you know if I have one hundred
sixty-two thousand people let that's how
many Guam has yeah if I had that for me
I'm set bro right if they're down if
they're down yeah
you want the kind of people that they'll
die for you if you have to it's never
gonna come down to that but yes do you
think you're somebody out there that
would what one of your fans it would not
for you oh I don't know
prot well there's crazy people out there
so so yes that's crazy bro but but but
you do too I got some people that might
[ __ ] pull their hair out yeah like you
and that's not a comment on how powerful
I am that's a comment on how sad people
are it is yeah you have people that
would probably at least like shock
themselves for you okay you know and I'm
talking about a heavy electric shock
yeah heavy heavy okay yeah yes I'm not
gonna shut them down or a failed attempt
yeah for me maybe jump off a building
yeah and be like well you know that's
gonna happen and you knew it how high
but if it's belief all right so you're
at probably maybe the two stories I'm in
somebody jumping off the balcony maybe
you're at like about six stories maybe
at all you got to get to that level
where you're just like though you know
but I don't know if there is but cuz
it's great but then but I don't know but
if you get to a crazier level a a Wilder
level of celebrity do you like at a
level now people might feel they can
have enough connection to you where they
can you know they would then do that
that they would kiss someone you would
kill themselves no I just feel like I
don't like it's it's a double-edged
sword like I like I like the fact that
people feel connected to me mm-hmm but
like you probably get this to like
people walk up to you and they're like
hey Theo yeah or like hey Theo what's up
and you're like oh do I know that person
right or is it a fan right and it's
confusing yeah like come up correct
right you like don't don't be like hey
Theo if I don't know you you don't know
the person's like hey Theo like what
yeah you're gonna be like oh man hey
listen your stuff good job right right
but like I was at the diner last night I
walked into the bathroom as I was
walking to the bathroom some do goes hey
that's Topher you're Topher that's the
character I played on workaholics don't
come at me like that it would just be
like
just be a person to be like oh I saw you
on workaholics great job like I'm don't
say I'm the guy you're not I mean yeah
[ __ ] out of here
yeah but also I have a weird thing and
it might be a shortcoming about how like
once somebody recognizes I've done
something I don't want to like like I
did that the drunk girls bit that I did
went viral and once and once that went
viral
I might I'll never do that on stage
again Wow I don't want to be like once
somebody knows me from something I don't
want to ever do it again
like I'm [ __ ] like I was one of the
first people on vine with a million
followers
I hated that app because everyone then
oh then it got real not funny right
people were like what's up when your
girl walks by and you know what and then
there's a McLaren in the vine for some
reason and you're like where'd they get
this [ __ ] McLaren from yeah
somebody's eating marshmallows or
something yeah yeah and and then some
guys just like oh you broke my armor
some [ __ ] and then you're like what what
is that and then that once that sort of
happened I stopped doing I've stopped
doing it and that app got corneas [ __ ]
that fast dude and then but for
something but I was one of the first
people with a million followers yeah so
people kind of a lot of people know me
you know were introduced to me from that
and I was already doing theaters as a
comedian before vine but people didn't
some people like those kids they don't
know 15 year-olds didn't know well they
probably can't even get into one of your
shows exactly so a lot of people know me
from vine and that's fine but to be like
oh you're from vine it's just it irks me
a little bitter oh and it's old yeah
well now yeah at this right it's fine to
be like I started watching you on the
vine okay sure yeah I get it
sure yeah I guess it's interesting
because I wonder if that urged us
because you know does that earth you
just because it's old like you know it's
um it's a fad that went away or does it
work you because it's like you know
because it's it's um it's not something
that you it's not where your best
entertainment is yeah it's like it's so
I look dude I get what it is it's right
easy it's it's it's eat well not that
it's easy but it's it's quick I don't
think about it do you know what I mean
I'm not I'm not like some of these
people on Instagram you see these
Instagram videos and they're cut
together and this and that like I'm
doing that [ __ ] yeah all my work goes
into my standup yeah all the more my
work goes into my standup do you know I
ain't like or or if I'm on a show or
something like I don't give a [ __ ] about
the Instagram is gonna be boom boom boom
that's it
IIIi think of a funny thing BAM and
people are like oh you know if people
are like what the [ __ ] this is stupid
no [ __ ] it's a social media I tweet [ __ ]
and people are like oh do that so stupid
no [ __ ] the [ __ ] is free yeah this is
social media this is what it's for dude
what do you want me to put well written
[ __ ] on Twitter get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah that's your come to a show yeah
[ __ ] do what about when people are
like oh I can't believe you were in town
just missed you oh dude that is the bang
bro dude it's so hard to not go nuts
yeah about that I go nuts about that
it's so I can't believe I missed you
can't believe I didn't know you were
here yeah well I'm you how about that
when they tagged it with this I'm your
biggest fan yeah no you're not I was in
your city two thousand people knew it
two thousand people sat in those seats
those fans there are two thousand eager
fans of me in your city yeah you
shouldn't even go outdoors bro bro
you're embarrassing yeah and it doesn't
even you don't even get it
and it's and it's and the fucked-up
thing is for me to say that it's
embarrassing
I sound elitist but [ __ ] that it is
still your embarrassing embarrassing and
here's what else you a fan of do you
love your mother do you love your
[ __ ] family you're healthy not no
probably not not as much as you think
you'd probably not as a matter of fact
if I had a son and he was whoever's
biggest fan and he missed their show
yeah and he said but I'm the biggest fan
I really might all relationship with
that son dude for real man oh definitely
does that's not cool bro that's not cool
you think there's a lot of dads that
ever hug their sons you mean like man my
Sonny [ __ ] you know what I hope so
yeah but I also hope that secretly they
were like but I [ __ ] up too yeah yeah
you know what I mean right like yeah
he's not [ __ ] but I'm all you know yeah
I'm realizing that I'm not [ __ ] either
he's not [ __ ] did you know what I'm
realizing if we had a podcast together
yeah it would take over anything III do
think so yeah well maybe we'll think
about that but yeah that would be
[ __ ] insane bro are you equal to a
yeah we're just so different though I
that's why it's good yeah just two white
guys kicking it oh yeah the endangered
species podcast because we're going out
of hucking business man yeah do you feel
alarmed being an alpha male in this time
period right now you seem to manage it
really well like I feel like a lot of
guys kind of move kind of pensively here
and there yeah you can't and not as a
comedian you can't do it who said this
bill burr said he was like well somebody
told me bill burr said this what but I'm
sure he did but it was very interesting
he was like he was like I'm 50 I
shouldn't be the edgy one yeah he's like
wow kids college kids think bill burr is
edgy and bill was saying this he's like
I shouldn't be the edgy one I should
have there should be 16 year olds that
are the edgy ones
yeah and he's [ __ ] right that's crazy
it's like the first time that that
hasn't had I know at what point you know
we're [ __ ] 38 at what point was it
was it were we edgier than the [ __ ]
17 year olds yeah because these kids at
college they're so scared of what to say
[ __ ] dude yo [ __ ] that yeah dude I will
you can't you can't
I mean imagine that imagine having this
feeling in your chest okay imagine all
the things you've ever wanted to say as
a comedian as a person and them just
stuck inside of you
oh yeah and not actually coming out into
the world bro that's where a lot of
these kids are probably living yeah
definitely and you know they're not well
look that's why to me being a comedian
is so fun and important it's like look I
get to say what I feel but also I'm
joking and you have to be you have to
say what you're feeling as a comedian
otherwise you know yeah what are you
doing you doing I mean you can I mean
look I have bits that don't mean
anything where I'm just [ __ ] around
being silly I like doing that tours sure
but you know if you come and you watch
my show for an hour there are things
that I feel and say that are also funny
that I think are funny that that are how
I feel and I'm not sorry about the jokes
you know do you feel more there moment
so were you like you know just because
now it is tougher to be an alpha male
bro it's tougher I think if you're
starting out now yeah as a white alpha
male so you're kind of you feel like
you're a little bit grandfathered in
kind of I mean just squeaked in I feel
like you know because yeah I think if
you're yeah I think it's tough for do it
I think it's tougher in you know in a
certain way I get you know if it's I
still feel like if you're a white guy
and you're born today you kind of won
the lotto right but yeah I agree but in
the entertainment industry
I think it's tougher to break in to
really you know yeah if you don't have
some sort of yeah I mean not that you
know right now I'll take anything away
from people who aren't know but it's not
it's not the most popular thing right
now
you know exactly yeah but do you think
now's a great time for somebody also to
go against the game so hard because this
like yeah well like that's like people
people who like people who are doing it
really well like Bill burr yeah like
who's a white guy who's 50 like people
who like that or like or like down for
that right there like these are fans
these people that jump from the
skyscraper yeah yeah I'm saying yeah
berkutov subscribe Scotty Oh jumpers
yeah do you notice that like cuz I
noticed that um that some comedians kind
of become celebrities mm-hmm and to me
burr has really remained a comedian
commedia yeah I admire that for sure a
hundred percent it's crazy like he pulls
up and I'm like oh this is yeah he's a
comedian
first I think it's hard to do that I
think it's hard to do that because but
also I think that if if the the reason
why he's that big is because of stand-up
whereas Kevin Hart he's a huge comedian
but I think the reason why he's that big
is because of movies right you know
there's nothing wrong with that I want
to do that yeah but but once like if
Bill burr I think was headlining him
movies then that would change right you
know what I'm saying do you think that
that's a desire thing for me I mean
obviously we don't know because we're at
him but I don't know it's like but there
is something from a comedians level
where you almost respect if you were
yeah bill more but you see him as the
true article still yeah that's true and
it a little bit has to do with you know
the way you look where we look at it you
know but I mean like like like Rogen's
the real deal you know and and Kevin
Hertz the real deal right but but
there's so much more there's so much
more yeah or than just the comedian
right so it's tough - it's tough to kind
of keep them in that box as comedian do
you shy away from things where and sorry
to just be grilling with all these
questions man but it's you know it's you
know I have some curiosities do you shot
like were the things that you shied away
from like like offers for things that
you've gotten you're like no [ __ ] way
even though it's a great offer like you
yeah yeah do you feel like you can make
those decisions for yourself just out of
the you don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean I've said no to a lot of things you
know that were good offers money or like
exposure maybe I guess and yeah I just
like I've turned down you know to be
leads and shows on network and it's just
because I just didn't you know it's like
I either done a version of that mm-hmm
you know which is why they're offering
it to me anyway because right I always
seen him do it I don't want to do that
yeah I've done it I did it like you want
to do something new well it's like I did
it and I know what it is and like like
doing a sitcom like I was on a sitcom
with a live audience for five years in a
row Whitney inundated oh right yeah and
then undateable and it's like after
Whitney I was like dude I don't wanna do
another sitcom unless it was perfect
undateable came along that was literally
the perfect sitcom for me to do you know
and then we're gonna go live forget it
yeah I'm not doing another sitcom after
that that was it I did it he did it yeah
so you know so I remember somebody came
they offered me uh something I can't
remember what the show was some of the
Pirates or something no see I would have
said yes in a heartbeat
that are you know what I mean just to do
that but I don't see how some moviemaker
doesn't look out and see like a ship
coming into a new land and you're on it
right dude
you're at the front maybe who you
telling draw I know I know I'm on the
front of that [ __ ] no dude and you have
both your legs still and people are yeah
how did he get 38 with both of those
legs yeah I'm still here cuz I'm still
here [ __ ] yeah dude
iiiii I'm telling you man I got this
movie coming out I think the end of this
year and that's what you shot in
Vancouver Toronto Toronto and I've never
said what it what I play Jaden Smith
right yeah but I don't know if I'm I
don't want to give too much away about
it but uh yeah it's definitely different
for me man like what do you play
I don't well you see it but it's called
a life in a year yeah and it's just
different and and they were like hey you
that you want they want you to do this
and I was like really and I was like aw
it's a comedy and they were like no and
I was like other than I'm there wow it's
a drama
you know she's dying of cancer Cara
Delevingne is dying of cancer and I'm
taking care of her I'm like her her
surrogate rental figure
oh really yeah I mean I'm not her actual
but yeah but you're her caretaker yeah
yeah so in was that um and that's what
Jaden Smith as well right yeah did you
meet Will Smith yeah good yeah yeah was
that yeah so he it was wild I mean he
saw me in he saw me in my outfit and
everything shooting the shot
what do you mean I feel like you're in a
bubble so are you Aaron and you are yeah
and he was like and he was like oh he
goes Wow and I was like I didn't ever
think I'd meet you like this and he was
like and it was like but this is it
you're the actor and you're playing this
and [ __ ] and then and then I I saw him
cuz he produced it wasn't me produced it
huh and then I saw him later in not the
outfit and he was like and he was like I
was like man you know how like when you
know somebody in the room you make eye
contact with you like it what's up well
when one of the when when that guy's
Will Smith
and you never don't think about it
you're gonna look we're gonna do this
right you can feel him you know ya never
looked at me once and then I realized oh
he doesn't know what I actually look
like oh he did cuz he saw you in the
other yeah yeah so I don't wanna give
too much away I don't even know if I'm
supposed to or not but like he's uh he
he's that whole family's amazing do it I
mean that family is like I'm there like
I don't understand I keep waiting for
like skeletons to come out yeah they're
just like the perfect family Jada will
willow willow yeah and Jaden Jaden yeah
and did it feel I mean did he seem like
a comedian did he seem like a mogul did
he seem like an actor he honestly seemed
like a dad and a cool guy yeah like a
like a role model they're like legit
yeah you know and and Jaden is a great
kid I mean he's like 19 now maybe but
like he's just like a cool dude did you
feel like you could pick up any kind of
swag points from a little bit like you
were like were you doing a little bit of
research cuz that guy I know he's cool
cuz he's wow he's like a ninja you know
he's like I know he does it all and do
and he and then his album came out
afterwards and I was like damn it's good
like he's good right he's he's good he's
talented for sure oh my god it's got to
be so [ __ ] hard for him to be Will
Smith's son you know I mean like and
then be in the entertainment business
it's like it's like I saw a video of
LeBrons kid playing basketball he's okay
well no they'd say oh he's really good
but it's like how good you gotta be how
good you gonna be yeah you gotta be the
best which you can't because your dad's
the best right so I'm saying dude
imagine if your [ __ ] dad was the best
so I'm saying it's like imagine oh uh uh
you know it's like any of them like
Meryl Streep's daughters doing she's an
actress
dude my dad was 70 when I was born right
I remember my dad [ __ ] he got this
Buick he bought it from some black dudes
in our neighborhood he couldn't hear
that good yeah it had 22s or something
the back of it right oh wow so he had
this Cutlass 88 and he would drive
around with just bass bro just takin her
sad yeah at 70 oh boy at 80 this is at
80 cuz he returned this is when I was 10
yeah and he would just drive around one
of the
blew out and he got a bunch of Chinese
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it literally rattled
for like two years just crust it out oh
my god I mean he was kind of great too
you know he lived by himself he had to
take care of himself but so you're
saying it would be easier for you to
become better oh yeah the finish line is
right next to the starting line
yeah but I can't imagine if that if your
dad is Will Smith how does your dad then
not how does your dad keep you from
feeling that pressure yeah I don't know
dude I don't know I mean it's one thing
if you're not gonna be in the business
then okay I get it
right but yeah dude I I don't know do
you feel like did that inspire you at
all to think like oh I could have a
family or this did that give you any
thoughts like that or like yeah yeah
sure I mean everything you experience in
life kind of shapes you a certain way to
a certain degree and I thought when I
yeah I probably I was like oh wow that's
cool you can do it cuz dude I hate when
something about me like I hate when
people break up man like it makes me
feel bad like like who's splitting up
now that I read and I'm like ah that
sucks like Chris Pratt and and oh yeah
you know I mean like I was like oh
that's a bummer when I saw that like
that sucks yeah I want there to be the
Hollywood couple that's like you know
what I mean that makes it yeah yeah my
buddy uh friend of on Josh Kelly Mary
Katherine Heigl and she's uh you know
she's from 27 dresses is that her yeah
and um four year oh no some of this yeah
yeah yeah she's a mattress yeah and
they've live out in Utah and they've
managed to like well there's every day
for like ten years
yeah yeah that's cool I wonder how
people do it I know there's so much
temptation I know I know well but also
you're never with each other if you're
doing that you know what I mean like
like like if you have a movie like
thinking about if you shoot Lord of the
Rings oh oh yeah I'm gonna be in New
Zealand for seven years
yeah oh and you're gonna be doing some
movies also in Toronto Vancouver and
then LA New Orleans yeah I'll see you
yeah there's none yeah how do you fill
that in yeah what do you do I'll see you
when were older yeah I'll see you in art
somebody else has raised our kids yeah I
know right yeah and a motel something
yeah just I don't know I don't know how
you do it pretty shocking yeah
do you feel like you'll be able to do
your podcast forever I don't know uh I
always say like dude if it's not growing
then what the [ __ ] am I doing it for
right so it's still growing and yeah
otherwise you know I don't I don't know
IIIi I do like that it's a lot of me
though and people subscribe to it
because that's that's me and of course
I'm doing a lot of jokes and silly
things on it but they know it's pure
it's like it's almost like we you're
saying like you like it when people are
there for you yeah yeah yeah like in the
same in almost the same way that
stand-up is you know yeah it's right
there yeah it's right there yeah did you
know like we need when you think back to
like some of your thoughts and stuff do
you have when you were younger did you
feel
did you know like and not even in like a
and like a [ __ ] up way or an egotist
boy did you know that you could be as
good as you are
um I think you kind of have to try to do
that yeah I I was like dude um I'm funny
like I know what's funny right and I
know how to translate that and I know
and I know that because it makes me
laugh right you know like like you know
I'm not doing it to make I'm not trying
to I mean I like when other people laugh
but if they don't get it I I don't care
I think that I think they're wrong I
think they're they're they're I don't I
don't think that they get it there I
don't think you know they have a
different sense of humor and it's not
that I want to say it's not as good but
yes they're missing something
yeah they're missing something yeah you
know it's interesting I know like one
thing I started to get back to a [ __ ]
that makes me laugh I'm like oh this if
it makes me laugh even chuckle even what
I'm thinking about about myself yeah I'm
like this is gonna be good well yeah
because you're funny and you know you're
funny because you're a comedian right
and you sell tickets right so if you
think it's funny then it's funny that's
it right so yeah in the end that matters
most for like even for young comedians
like it might not translate to the
audience at this moment but if you
believe that that is funny you know it
yeah yeah and I have sometimes on my
stage where I'm like I you know rarely
I'll be like this is funny you
[ __ ] only some you were
laughing like
[ __ ] it [ __ ] this you know and you know
maybe that's my fault but that's what
keeps it moving that's what keeps me you
know going do you feel like um do you
like so you got to this million
followers and that you feel like you
kind of like you kind of won that what
do you mean like like you like you see
almost it's like you beat the video game
a little yeah yeah I guess you're yeah
do was there moments where you're like
like you put stuff out you're like oh
[ __ ]
nah I mean I mean cuz you're pretty
prolific Lee you put out a lot of stuff
and it's good I mean it's obviously like
thanks but I just uh like we use that
concerned on it no yeah no no no no cuz
it's just Instagram right you know what
I mean it's not like like if I'm gonna
shoot a special then yeah I'm like
should I cut that bit out I put this bit
in chat you know I mean because that's
like my art Instagram is not my art it
rise high you follow me on a daily basis
or whatever the [ __ ] you know right so
and I mean you gotta you gotta let
yourself do that and if somebody's gonna
be like oh you shouldn't oppose to this
all right
[ __ ] okay right that's you that's you
yeah you know Nick did we have another
calling question that came in my name is
grace Ann and I have a question for
Chris and Theo if you had your dream
comedy festival what group of comedians
would you want to headline it and where
would you want it to be it's a good
question man I would go to Chicago and I
would go with I go with Chris Rogan I
would go with I'll probably go with
Eddie Bravo was the emcee cuz that guy's
so crazy pal he's spent time around him
no I know you've been on your podcast
and snow bright I saw him last night
dude he's so interesting bro he was he
was cool he came up to me last night
he's so interesting yes oh yeah I know
he's definitely interesting Nikki Glaser
maybe we yeah Whitney Cummings you know
if I was trying to you know really make
it you know just trying to diversify the
thing
Santino yeah Fahim yeah how many people
can be on this thing I guess what's the
festival a lot that's a good point
yeah I could keep going
and in Chicago is where I would do it
yeah um that's cool I'd like I'd like to
do it one in LA you know what I mean Wow
I mean it's makes no sense b-but because
you know you can just but uh I'll age I
love it
I'll get there my second special in LA
because I'm LA dude right like all these
[ __ ] oh you gotta be from boss you
got me from New York you gotta be from
Chicago eat my [ __ ] dick bro yeah
y-yeah have bits of my dick for you yeah
I mean III I'm from New Jersey but I
started stand-up in LA [ __ ] that yeah
that [ __ ] is but how many people try to
get you to rep Jesse though every yeah
I'm from New Jersey
but like wow did not even realize that
you definitely seem like something from
PI Jersey I know I do I know I do
Wow two parks at East Coast born West
Coast raised that's me man that is you
huh that's what he did he moved from
Baltimore to [ __ ] you know like we
heard that do you feel like you fit
right into that when you heard Tupac say
that yeah yeah yeah yeah to pasta the go
you seem to navigate like on this level
that's just so comfortable man is it it
means a lot is that just a car is that
you know like you just seem to manage
your own like confidence and yeah it's
like you're I think I've worked on it
you know um I think a lot about myself
in either in an egotistical way or in a
well I should because I'm me
right I mean and because your own
business and all yeah at that - yeah and
so you have to i remember reading an
article a long time ago about somebody
saying something online and getting in
trouble for it this is before all of
this outrage culture right and i was
like oh [ __ ] I don't ever want that to
happen to me I better [ __ ] let
[ __ ] know who I am
mm-hmm so they know what they're gonna
get mmm you know I'm saying if right
like take Chris who's the Captain
America Chris Evans mm-hmm if this guy
was like uh I've made the joke my first
special seven years ago when black dudes
laugh they relocate yeah and when they
laugh they [ __ ] right I've met a
black dude laughs
hard once he drove to Vegas right so if
[ __ ] crisp Evan said that on Twitter
yeah they would light him up they'd be
like oh you're racist but like he's not
know but he's just this guy who was like
you know an actor that's like a good guy
that's like it's like [ __ ] dude that
shit's all facade anyway you know me
right
this is what I say if you don't like it
get off the boat right that's it go
shopping yeah I like that is if that
makes me think to to really just lay
down the line of you know figure out
what my line is and lay it they do it
that way dude but that that's what being
a comedian is man I mean like look at
Joey Diaz he's the best the best version
of that yeah you know what I mean
yeah sometimes I guess I I get fearful
sometimes you know I think I get less
and less four years out here I was like
I didn't even know who I was you know I
think I knew a little bit but I just was
afraid you know I feel like I had to fit
into this box or like be this way anyway
you know I hate it I just I don't know I
hated it but also you know the I mean
people knew you from a different thing
right oh yeah that was tough to overcome
that yeah I mean now you're not that and
that that's hard to do but you know it's
like you know time has to pass and then
you gotta get you know it's like but
time has to pass for sure yeah and then
you have to I mean that should put a
chip on my shoulder man oh I bet it did
because I lived out here and people were
like [ __ ] this dude oh yeah no doubt but
it made you [ __ ] better for sure it
made you a funnier person yeah because
you got because that's what gives you
that alright [ __ ] these people they
don't know me this is why I am
[ __ ] what also made me think oh
if this industry these people gonna act
this way towards me then I'm gonna take
the thing that they prize the most that
they say is like the hardest thing to do
in the whole world and I'm gonna [ __ ]
do that interesting good I'm gonna do
that so good that they can't say
anything yeah what are they gonna say
then yeah [ __ ] Muppet so somebody
Muppets out of here
well that's I'm saying you get your
podcast you're in control of it yeah I
like that more now do you feel more in
control a little bit as you like do you
feel like it's headed more that way in
some ways yeah yeah yeah yeah I wanna I
wanna I want to have my channel whether
it's on YouTube or my app or
my podcast is like I want I want it to
be my channel it's me it's my channel
we're do you think the desire from like
just to have to I mean you have like it
a thing it's not like you want to be the
best but you want to be the best you
want to do everything you can do I want
to be this sounds so corny but like I
want to be me I want to be the best
version of me and I think you know
there's enough people out there that
like that guy and I want to find all of
them yeah you know but that's what being
a comedian is I think do you have
visions oh no especially now like the
world kind of ends and [ __ ] and then you
guys are all in a like someplace that's
made up out of like used cars and all
stacked together and there's walls and
stuff I don't know yes I always imagined
that when I'm like older like that I
would be on you know like a cabin with
like a bunch of tall grass surrounding
it and like we'd go outside and like
talk about ideas and make fun of each
other and that I mean you got some
people that are gonna cook in you got
some people that are good at you know
entertainments there's no [ __ ]
guitars nobody's playing that [ __ ]
no like listen to this [ __ ] get out
of here that [ __ ] you know don't change
the tone of the whole goddamn thing with
music you know I'm talking about my [ __ ]
is I don't [ __ ] with music either when I
get up when I get out there I don't do
that we don't bring our iPod [ __ ]
bullets we don't do that whatever the
[ __ ] those beats we don't do that we
don't [ __ ] with that we talk we [ __ ]
laugh we eat good food and we [ __ ] dude
yeah you know and there's chicks out
there tears chicks and dudes and but
sometimes even if it's dudes [ __ ]
that's okay yeah it's absolutely okay
but it's also sepra Sep it's it's
separated to like this alright this
party's for dudes no chick right you
know what I mean and you girls have your
own [ __ ] you know but I'll fishing you
go fishing with the guys you could you
could yeah you could you could yeah
there's a probably you know do you go or
do you just kind of think I go no I
think I just chill and then they bring
the fish back and then you know yeah you
make fun of everybody at the fish yup
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's great dude
I don't even know if there's currency
yeah it's just you know it's just and
you can jerk off and calm and like the
Oh chicks can you know what I mean
whatever
- whatever and is there any shame if
people are jerking off and stuff I mean
you don't jerk off in front of people if
they don't want you to jerk off it's a
lot like life but like but like you
don't you know but also there's like
that room where it's like oh that's the
jerk-off room you want to go in there
just right go chill and like chicks will
be there watching you jerk off and you
can they can jerk off if they one can
[ __ ] you know what I mean yeah it's like
a crazy room yeah how do you die man how
do you die because no because I like it
you know when I listen to your acting
stuff and I see you like have these you
know like you get these visions and like
you know and you talk about how like you
know it's them it's life as a movie and
there's this thing you know and you how
do you die man cuz it has to be
something neat yeah you can't die in a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass way like in a like in
a hospital can you I don't want to I
think that like this cookies and [ __ ] on
the table or something in this [ __ ]
yeah somebody's supposed to be there
with you and they got a call or in the
[ __ ] hallway yeah you died um I think
that uh I you either this is how you go
you either you you're in your bed mm-hmm
at home mm-hmm you just have a
malfunction and pass away if you can't
get that mm-hmm
there's no oh he's got he's got cancer
he got taken to a hospital for [ __ ]
to two months and he dies there I'm not
doing that [ __ ] yeah bro
don't do that now uh oh [ __ ] he's on his
last leg I don't ever want anybody
saying that [ __ ] about me right why cuz
you don't want that news to get out or
you know I just know I don't want that's
boring regular [ __ ] yeah I want I think
honestly a cool way to go hmm
you gotta do something I know but who
knows if I'll be big then you know what
I mean who knows if I'll have my if I
have my think it'd be cool to like if
somebody like if somebody poisoned me
like that I like really like if I broke
their heart and then they poisoned me
like some real like Korean [ __ ] yeah
they're not I'm saying or like no
Japanese I guess it would be Japanese I
don't mean to be racist but now look
either one does a lot of Korean no
Korean is a lot a lot of a lot of
revenge
yeah yeah that most multi-factor ever
been a movie in made by Koreans or
Japanese that wasn't about revenge yeah
but a lot of poison meat - in all their
films there's a lot of food poison so so
yeah so like if I broke a car and I
probably you already did the thing that
whatever you are its you've already done
waiting that's buried you're milling in
the distance you've done it you've done
it you've done the thing that ruins you
you're done if I ran for president it's
already over yeah way yeah me too just
cuz a couple of texts have probably sent
100% now I could see this maybe you're
at a diner right here in the mountains
right your truck breaks down right and
you thought yet you like and you have a
dog in the back you try can't even
[ __ ] serve it to your dog but it fits
the vision right so you walk up you walk
up to this diner right you get in you
call you know maybe Michael anoche or
somebody or maybe even um you know Chris
Pine or somebody I know him yeah and you
call them and they're like yeah we'll
come help you yeah and you but in the
meantime you're gonna wait you can have
a sandwich
right and they don't have anything on
the menu that you like you know for a
walk go figure right but the lady says
that they can make you something special
she says we have a special of the day
and it happens to be like your favorite
food like oh that's wild so you get it
you're sitting there eating right you
take two bites and then you realize
you're poison you look in the distance
and the waitress or the manager is an
old flame something wrong yep yeah
that's a way to go and I'll tell you
what to you Bruce and you would spy
would 100% respect I'd be scared of [ __ ]
I would cry probably but but I would but
to have that gentle conversation where
they sit down and they let you know what
happened and they're like listen i
poisoned you this is it there's nothing
you can do about it
you broke my heart you know and and I
loved you and you really hurt me in in
you know 2008 or whatever it was yeah
and you've lived your whole life you're
77 and I never got remarried I never had
another guy I always you were always a
person on my mind and I have to kill you
before I die and that's what I did and
I'm sorry but I had to do that for me
do
tears running down my face man and I eat
the rest of that [ __ ] [ __ ] before I
die to me at all give me a nominee you
have this special [ __ ] give it to me
I'll ingest it and I'll die dude I feel
like crying right now man yeah and
that's how I'm gonna go that's how I
want to go dude and no [ __ ] that's
how I want to go and if I take those
last few bites and I feel the poison
swell my throat up and I look over at
that my dog not my dog whatever the [ __ ]
that dog is sitting in that truck and
I'm waiting for [ __ ] you know either
my opener or Chris Pine to get there and
they they die before that I die before
that bro but I'm looking at that dog and
I'm wondering is that dog - that dog not
mine that's the last [ __ ] thought I
have and I'm holding the girl's hand and
she gets it and it's like I'm so sorry
honey
yeah man that's the feel that's a real
way that's the real way bro because that
would mean something at the last moment
you'd be having at least an effect even
if that effect is that you are letting
them have that mode even if it's yeah it
would be something real yeah yeah it's
like you're like this Neil Armstrong for
like real [ __ ] sometimes man that's just
emotional yeah I I yeah I would go that
way I would like to go that way actually
what would you go into battle could see
maybe going well that's another way with
a sword but not with a gun no no no no
no but I don't want to get like all cut
up yeah soft battle maybe like slap
battle he died keep that getting sort
out a lot that's West I got one more
question and I want to ask you so you
had like you know you had the thing with
the Logan Paul thing that happened right
in hinds like and you know he kind of
called you out and then you kind of
burned him a little bit but um is that
safe to say yeah I mean I think I I
think I probably started it I I just
well but I mean I just meant it as like
a he was like last blog it's important
and I wrote no it's not no it's not yeah
but I mean like that's because like I
would first of all it's not your last
blog
yeah second of all it's not Borton yeah
and you know that yeah and do you think
did you know that was gonna go as crazy
is it no no I didn't think you'd respond
yeah
he responded his what bait that's what
really when he responded oh also it's
like when he respond it was when he
responded it was like is that word
responded I'm getting off yes
he was fond he responded and he was like
uh-uh I know and I looked at it and I
was like oh damn I was like I almost
immediately kind of felt bad for him
yeah because I was like this is gonna be
horrible for you right because this is
what I do
yes that's true and also everybody
already doesn't like you
right so it's easy for me mmm and I was
like oh I have the as soon as I saw it I
was like I got the best thing to say
yeah this is what you'd say and I
thought about it and I'm like this is
the thing to say yeah and I posted it I
went to bed yeah and I woke up and it
was like I was on The Tonight Show in
1985 ha ha it was like people were like
hey man what's up
drunk driving walking down the street
doesn't Jesus Christ real Arius yeah
dude was hilarious
it was hilarious I'll go to the gym
people like hey man [ __ ] take that guy
down it was some guy at the gym yeah
yeah and there it is kita there and I
and I'm having fun you know I'm sure yes
I always say people aren't what they say
they're who they are and I think we've
lost sight of that in this 100 and age
it's like somebody says something or
like I'll [ __ ] that guy and you know
this kid did that thing he did a dumb
thing I'm gonna take the benefit of the
doubt I'm gonna have I'm gonna say he
knows that that was dumb yeah
I'm sure if you were to do it he
wouldn't do it again and not because of
it would ruin his business but because
he knows that that's a [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] thing to do Yeah right I'm sure
he's a good guy I'm sure he's a good kid
I'm gonna take the benefit of the doubt
I'm sure he's a good guy I probably when
I hung out with if I were to ever hang
out with him I probably be like this
guys are [ __ ] annoying his [ __ ] yeah
but like I would just playfully be like
yeah you [ __ ] idiot what the hell
you're so stupid don't do that [ __ ] and
you'd probably laugh it off and we'd be
probably like oh you're [ __ ] you're
stupid too cuz of this and maybe we get
along yeah I like that [ __ ] but
then he kept going and in my mind he's
just having fun but I don't know maybe
not maybe he is actually angry at me cuz
I'm just having fun - it's just fun it's
just funny like what are you doing don't
do this - first of all don't do this
don't do this - a comedian right period
because this is their job right and
you're an adult yes there's that - but
also don't do it to me yeah I'm
definitely gonna write back right I'm
not Jerry Seinfeld right who's just like
oh you [ __ ] wrote that about me uh who
wants to waste time on that guy right I
am petty [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna do it the [ __ ]
was there any aftermath that people
didn't see like was their communication
after we're like he reached out or you
reached out or you know the dude or any
publicist reach out that no what's
what's today
no there's nothing no no no just
everybody talked about it yeah I gave
just it was just wild I got a lot of
followers off of it which is I didn't
really expect it was insane it was I
guess I never had much did ya it got
more favorites and retweets than any
Donald Trump yeah it got nice em yeah
Wow yeah what yeah wild yeah it was it
was huge it was huge it was huge as a
matter of fact it happened the same week
that that Kanye thing happened where he
said slavery was a choice mhm
I wonder if that if that didn't happen
how big it would have been hmm because
that should all obviously took over the
whole world yeah like yeah it was so
crazy how big it went yeah did you know
that something could hit that big like
did it even believe had it blown your
mind a little bit it was funny yeah I
was like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah I guess that's a lot Wow
six hundred sixty-four thousand likes
hundred forty nine thousand that's Guam
let's everybody in Guam few times over
but everybody in Guam with the retweets
right yeah 160 mm oh yeah yeah yeah with
the retweets yeah but yeah what if
everyone who read tweeted it was just
everyone in Guam yeah that was just like
a [ __ ] dude if you met Chris Lee you
think you you think he was cool
think about him me yeah yeah I would
think he would be like I would be I
would be mad that that guy's already
doing it yeah well I want to do know it
sometimes I felt like that what about
you in the past like you're so kind of
you know you you go so quick and so
confidently into so many little spaces
and big spaces but that it's like [ __ ]
dude I you know I thought about this but
now he did it so now it's like it's kind
of hack you know Wow I don't know you
don't really hold people to that now you
know cuz it's like everybody can do
whatever yeah you think your own [ __ ]
but um but yeah me do you ever feel like
you've been on this like vibration a
little bit that's like kind of like this
this humor vibration or something where
I think there's a wavelength and I think
that you have it I think that if you're
a truly if you're a funny person you you
are just that you're kind of like I
don't know if you're born with it or if
it your childhood it develops or what I
don't I don't know if you're born with
it but but you see these guys I've
talked about this on my podcast but you
see these guys on Instagram trying to
trying to ride this wave length and
they're just not on it yeah and they're
just doing all of the things that a
funny person does but it's and they
because it's what they think that a
funny person does but it's just not
translating because they're not on the
wavelength yeah oh yeah that's what they
that's what it that's what that's the
idea it's like I saw it's like I saw a
horror movie the other night I'm not
going to say what it is because I'm
because you in it mMmmm no but it's I'm
not gonna say what it is but everyone
loves it
and I and it was it was fine but it just
had a lot of things that horror movies
have in it because it felt like oh
that's what a horror movie has yeah and
it's just not it's it's like that's what
it's like I think with humor it's I say
it's like you're either on the web like
that you're not
guys like Will Ferrell are [ __ ]
hilarious he's on it you know what I
mean but then there are other guys you
can figure it out make a career mm-hmm
but you're just getting the people that
are all aren't on the wavelength right
you know and you think the weight comes
from me it's it's almost like a it's
just at your own wavelength yeah well
yeah I think it's a web
- like like Bobby Lee's on it yes a
hundred percent yeah guys just you know
what I mean you're on it you know
Santino's on it yeah and it's just like
Fahim it's like it's just funny it's
just how the people are Whitney's on it
it's just like you know it's do you
think it's kind of fascinating that
humor is this thing so say if like you
make me laugh right yeah like I make a
sound and I shake at the same time like
like that's what laughter is like it's
pretty weird yeah it is very weird it's
very weird I think about it yeah it's
like coming out of your heart yeah a
little bit yeah it's a weird thing like
laughing dude how about some people just
don't laugh we're just don't laughing
they don't like imagine being like a
Wall Street guy and just doing your job
not really no one thinking Karen what's
funny yeah not making jokes right not
thinking of your own stuff yeah that is
all day long all broke all I'm doing is
thinking of what's fun yeah that's all
I'm doing I'm looking at [ __ ] why is
that funny wise it's funny cuz that's
what's fun to me
Wow people don't do that even a little
bit yeah what are you doing yeah yeah
it's baffling when you have that access
to have this thing that makes you
laughter so weird bro that you can say
and do something that that does
something into somebody's head and then
immediately into their emotions and then
they make a you know yeah shake yeah
it's so weird they're not even thinking
about it
it happens it just happens it's not like
sleeping it's not like anything else
right you just it's involuntary yeah you
came like oh my goo laughs now yeah it's
a yes yeah I'm gonna have enough for
eight hours yeah it's almost like
Tourette's yeah [ __ ] yeah what you can
run control of it you just got to do it
and you know in the it's almost like
here a [ __ ] sorcerer bro because you
know how to make them do this you have
powers yeah you're like yeah do we even
know they were calling questions I think
we have one more Chris yeah hey this is
Klan ask Chris why he looks so pissed
off yeah I know I know first of all his
name's Quinn no it's hers I mean it hey
this is Clint Clint Clint Clint with an
in for a little alright first of all
all right so yeah [ __ ] with an end yeah
so all right all right Clint really
never met anybody named Clint in my life
and I never will and I wonder % never
will and I know that I know I'll never
met a guy named Clint it was no [ __ ]
way if some guy actually yeah if I were
ever to meet a guy named Clint it would
be the day I get poison at that diner
I'll tell you that
so can't even imagine you talking about
him yeah I know imagine me talking to a
guy named Clint Han no I know dude I'm
trying to think about I don't even Who
am I with in there you know what I am
what when I picture a me talking to a
guy named Clint I'm that [ __ ] shadow
emoji yeah you know I'm talking about
who uses that that's what that is that
is emoji is the emoji of me talking to a
guy named Clint that's what that's what
they created that emoji for that we do
about the hojin with a guy with crystal
he's talking about him Clint oh I got it
it's a shadow we got it put it on yeah
and then you know there's the two shadow
emoji that's me you're talking to a guy
so um why do I was like pissed off I
know I have that I don't mean to have
that it I think it's cause I'm always
thinking and in my own world in my own
head but like I had a I was with who was
I with I don't remember who I was with
but I was shopping
oh my buddy Cedric I don't talk to him
anymore but um she she came up and she
said hey do you guys need any help and I
was like nah we're good were just
hanging around she says okay and I don't
know how the conversation happen but I
was like I asked her I was like oh she
said something like oh yeah you guys
don't look like you need any help I just
wanted to check and I was like what and
she was like well you just look like you
don't want to be bothered and I was like
oh oh yeah and I was like do I look like
that and she was like yeah I was like
like I look like unapproachable or what
and she was like you just looked like
you're thinking about something or like
you're you're you're upset and I'm like
oh weird I'm not upset at all and that
was when I realized I mean this was I
was like 219 yeah and that's when you
realized oh I exude that on my face but
I don't mean to and I think I'm getting
these wrinkles here because of it right
I just noticed a few weeks ago but yeah
I'm just always thinking about [ __ ]
right not interested not smart things
it's interesting but not smart thing did
you um I used to hit like my eyes go
right down
here in the middle highbrows going in
yeah and I would free years bro for
literally probably 15 years I would hold
my [ __ ] eyes open open yeah just cuz
I was so self-conscious about how I saw
me it makes a lot of sense I've seen you
when I think of you in my head you're
doing that not really
yeah maybe fun I'm not [ __ ] around
either I know you know that's okay but
you have good skin though yeah but it's
I mean it's okay but it's not I just
don't want to be like that forever
well you're still young you know yeah
you're not even 40 yet do you do you
have a thing against a age I've kind of
I mean there's things I want to do I
guess but it's all about accomplishment
like I feel like I've I'm accomplishing
things that I want to accomplish and I'm
happy so you know so you don't feel that
burden like is I think a lot of men feel
that burden of like you know I want I
have to I mean a little bit yeah I
definitely I can't say I don't but like
but having some sense of achievement
yeah yeah
it probably makes it it gives it a
little bit more of a peaceful look at
your landscape yeah definitely yeah but
yeah I mean you know I have I have a
good life I'm happy you know I'm able to
do what I want to do and I'm 38 and
that's awesome yeah I mean it's cool man
everyone hates their job I don't right
so yeah and you bring people into your
fold man and I think that that's neat
you know I do think it's a you know cuz
some people could be you know kind of
super greedy and you don't be that way
ya know [ __ ] it who cares yeah well I
think it's nice man um I appreciate you
so much for coming in today bro
whoo this is fun man I'm glad I did dude
if you ever have I guess my
congratulations okay yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna opt for sure I'll probably do that
some at some point yeah yeah yeah we'll
be funnier on there we don't sometimes
it'll don't be refining on here
oh really yeah really yeah we don't like
do we we don't really I mean off-court
Clips your [ __ ] yeah you ask real
questions but but that's good though but
yeah but here's what's funny to me yeah
yeah but you're funny though so you
don't have to be funny do you no I mean
yeah yeah I think somehow I'm in the in
the solo episodes I it's it's more funny
hmm but it's to me it's just interesting
like you know just to think about just
you know cuz I get curious about the way
their peers especially guys that I
admire
behave and what makes him kind of tick
one last question so you have a brother
right and you love I said yeah I saw a
funny video you your dad and your
brother the other day when you guys
looking at piece of mail
it's almost as [ __ ] a little bit of
like a suburban Seinfeld in a weird way
but - was there ever a point where you
started to really feel like you were
getting like pop isn't like you're
starting to get popular yeah and you
were worried about like how your brother
might um like relate to you or you
didn't want sure like him nuh uh yeah of
course I I mean just I don't it you know
it it family's a weird thing that way
because my dad would start to you know
he's a professional in his own right
right he's a famous producer
yeah and director producer director
pretend uh and he and and people now say
to him you know he jokes around about it
he's like now I know I'm Krista Leah's
dad what the [ __ ] and you know that's
family I don't ever want anything from
my professional world to taint or make
family stuff weird I know that they're
all very proud of me and I'm very proud
of them but my brother is like a version
of me like I would I would do anything
for my brother more than I would do
anything for anyone else I would I would
fly to Guam right now for my brother if
he needed me and and and and I wouldn't
do that for anybody yeah so I'm always I
always you know look my brother's a
director writer and he's done stuff and
is doing stuff now and as long as he's
happy in his own perfect my brother
doesn't want to be famous or anything
right there's not that but uh but he
wants to be valued for his work and I
think he is and he's [ __ ] super
talented and honestly I feel that way
about him a lot I feel like I feel like
a [ __ ] man I'm this comedian up there
talking about my dick yeah or [ __ ]
or whatever the [ __ ] right Australia or
whatever the [ __ ] I decide to talk about
my brother's doing real actual [ __ ]
that's like so good
I mean he's so talented so it's like
it's like yeah it so I feel that way too
you know about him you admire him yeah I
mean the guys yeah the guy's one of the
most talented guys yeah period yeah he's
great and he's [ __ ] hilarious and he's
cool he I was thought like he was like
the cool one like oh no he's like sexy
and she's got long hair girls was like
what's his deal he only wears corduroys
like who the [ __ ] that's Louie you know
I mean it never wears jeans you know
else does that Paddington Bear I think
he other person yeah the two people who
do that are my brother and up there yeah
that's the [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] awesome
and when people can check out
congratulations podcast Nick was there
anything else that we wanted to just
real rapid-fire weed we tried to take
some Instagram questions there weren't a
lot of ones but rapid fire I want to
give you three how [ __ ] it's okay
how [ __ ] is it to cover yourself from
the rain with your hands wants us truck
back what oh it's the act okay uh it's
it's it's uh it's a little [ __ ] the Sun
though what about the Sun is even worse
that's that's more [ __ ] yeah that's
more [ __ ] uh yeah from at Aaron spam
Ewell's how [ __ ] is it to blow out
birthday candles it depends it depends
on how you do it honestly if you're you
know what I mean if you're if you're if
you're just like and you do it fine but
if you you can be [ __ ] about pretty
much anything people don't really get
the bit that how [ __ ] is it thing
really [ __ ] to get out of to get in or
out of the the a two door car to get in
the backseat really [ __ ] because you're
like oh oh yeah I'm really [ __ ] now
what about this what if somebody put out
their birthday candles with a little
bitty [ __ ] over there so [ __ ] no [ __ ]
yes so [ __ ] one more how [ __ ] is it to
tiptoe out of the shower to find your
towel if you forgot it from theater
that's pretty [ __ ]
thanks so much Nick Chris Lea thanks so
much for being here bro thanks man I had
a good time too I'm a huge fan and I
love your work man meeting you too same
thing you know it hundred percent
alright dude thanks a lot
yep
on the breeze and not feel of tolling
like these leaves I must be oh but when
I reach that round I'll share this peace
of mind I can feel it but it's gonna
take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]